[Music]
if you
sucked all of the moisture out of your
brain
and broke it down to its constituent
nutritional content
what would it look like most of the
weight of your dehydrated brain
would come from fats also known as
lipids
in the remaining brain matter you would
find proteins and amino acids
traces of micronutrients and glucose
the brain is of course more than just
the sum of its nutritional parts
but each component does have a distinct
impact
on functioning development mood and
energy
so that post lunch apathy or late night
alertness you might be feeling
well that could simply be the effects of
food
on your brain of the fats in your brain
the superstars
are omegas three and six these essential
fatty acids
which have been linked to preventing
degenerative brain conditions
must come from our diets so eating
omega-rich foods like nuts
seeds and fatty fish is crucial to the
creation
and maintenance of cell membranes and
while omegas are good fats for your
brain
long-term consumption of other fats like
trans
and saturated fats may compromise brain
health
meanwhile proteins and amino acids the
building block nutrients of growth and
development
manipulate how we feel and behave
amino acids contain the precursors to
neurotransmitters
the chemical messengers that carry
signals between neurons
affecting things like mood sleep
attentiveness
and weight they're one of the reasons we
might feel
calm after eating a large plate of pasta
or more alert after a protein-rich meal
the complex combinations of compounds in
food
can stimulate brain cells to release
mood altering
norepinephrine dopamine and serotonin
but getting to your brain cells is
tricky and amino acids have to compete
for limited access
a diet with a range of foods helps
maintain a balanced combination
of brain messengers and keeps your mood
from getting skewed in one direction
or the other like the other organs in
our bodies
our brains also benefit from a steady
supply of micronutrients
antioxidants in fruits and vegetables
strengthen the brain to fight off free
radicals
that destroy brain cells enabling your
brain to work well for a longer period
of time
and without powerful micronutrients like
the vitamins b6
b12 and folic acid our brains would be
susceptible to brain disease
and mental decline trace amounts of the
minerals
iron copper zinc and sodium are also
fundamental to brain health
and early cognitive development in order
for the brain to efficiently transform
and synthesize these valuable nutrients
it needs fuel and lots of it
while the human brain only makes up
about 2 percent of our body weight
it uses up to 20 percent of our energy
resources
most of this energy comes from
carbohydrates that our body digests into
glucose
or blood sugar the frontal lobes are so
sensitive to drops in glucose in fact
that a change in mental function
is one of the primary signals of
nutrient deficiency
assuming that we are getting glucose
regularly how does the specific
type of carbohydrates we eat affect our
brains
carbs come in three forms starch sugar
and fiber while on most nutrition labels
they are all lumped into one
total carb count the ratio of the sugar
and fiber
subgroups to the whole amount affect how
the body and brain respond
a high glycemic food like white bread
causes a rapid release of glucose into
the blood
and then comes the dip blood sugar
shoots down and with it
our attention span and mood on the other
hand
oats grains and legumes have slower
glucose release
enabling a steadier level of
attentiveness
for sustained brain power opting for a
varied diet of nutrient-rich foods
is critical when it comes to what you
bite chew
and swallow your choices have a direct
and long-lasting
effect on the most powerful organ in
your body
[Music]
you